Transcription: Juliette Bruneel
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour à tous.
Aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter
l'histoire de Pierre.
Pierre a une grande idée.
Il a des capacités, il tient un concept.
Et pourtant, il ne fait rien.
Il ne fait rien
parce qu'un grand danger le guette.
Le grand danger : le manque de temps.
On a tous envie de changer les choses,
petites ou grandes.
Et pourtant, je suis sûre que comme moi,
vous dites régulièrement cette phrase :
« Je n'ai pas le temps », ou
« Je n'ai pas pris le temps ».
Mon objectif aujourd'hui :
vous délivrer 3 clés
pour prendre le temps d'aller vite
et aller au bout de vos idées.
Alors comment aider Pierre ?
Pour aider Pierre, on va d'abord
jouer au jeu de la balle.
Le jeu de la balle, c'est un jeu simple
où des participants dans un groupe
se passent une balle de manière aléatoire.
Aléatoire, ça veut dire
que chaque participant
n'aura pas le droit de passer la balle
à son voisin,
et la balle ne pourra passer
que par un participant.
Je vais ensuite introduire
une notion de timing.
Je vais les chronométrer.
Au départ, les participants restent assis,
et sont principalement centrés
sur leurs performances individuelles,
c'est-à-dire bien recevoir la balle,
bien l'envoyer à la bonne personne.
Sur cette première phase,
les groupes arrivent en moyenne
à descendre leur timing
pour environ le diviser par deux.
A chaque fin de tour, je demande :
« Pensez-vous pouvoir faire mieux ? »
A un certain moment, le groupe me dit :
« Non, on ne peut pas faire mieux ».
Il y a toujours un esprit avisé
pour remettre en cause l'organisation
et proposer de se mettre debout.
Alors, on peut voir sur l'image de gauche
qu'au départ, c'est un peu le chaos,
les participants cherchent leur place,
discutent,
ça va consommer plusieurs minutes
pour trouver la bonne organisation.
Quand l'organisation est mise en œuvre,
très rapidement, un ou 2 passages,
le temps est divisé par trois,
c'est-à-dire qu'on passe
de 45 à 15 secondes.
Quand le temps est optimisé,
le groupe, à la question :
« Pensez-vous pouvoir faire mieux ? »
va de nouveau me répondre « Non ».
Un participant propose toujours,
systématiquement,
d'imaginer une façon de travailler
qu'ils n'avaient jamais pensée.
C'est la remise en question des règles.
Avec ce groupe-là,
la stratégie qui a été adoptée
c'était de poser le doigt sur la balle.
J'ai vu plein de stratégies différentes,
la main dessous, la main au-dessus,
et puis d'autres idées
un peu plus farfelues.
Ce qu'on peut retenir de cette expérience,
et si on veut aider Pierre,
Pierre doit se demander
dans quelle phase il est.
Est-il dans la phase 1 où il doit
optimiser ses tâches individuelles ?
Est-il dans la phase 2
où il doit se poser la question
de la communication avec les autres
et de sa place
dans l'environnement de travail ?
La gestion de l'espace
est dans cette étape-là.
Et la question 3, doit-il imaginer
une nouvelle façon de travailler ?
La deuxième question
à laquelle il doit répondre
« Ai-je optimisé mon temps ? Si oui,
je dois passer à l'étape suivante. »
La deuxième clé
que je voulais vous délivrer,
c'est la métaphore des grosses pierres.
Vous la connaissez peut-être déjà,
c'est l'histoire d'un conférencier
qui place successivement dans un bidon
des grosses pierres, puis du gravier,
du sable, et enfin de l'eau.
Alors quand on parle de gestion du temps,
on pourrait facilement penser
que cette métaphore sert à montrer
qu'il y a toujours un petit peu de temps.
On peut toujours caser
quelque chose de plus.
En réalité, l'enseignement est tout autre.
L'enseignement dit
que ce qui est important,
c'est l'ordre dans lequel
on place les choses.
Si je ne place pas
les grosses pierres en premier,
il n'y aura jamais la place
pour les mettre.
L'exemple est simple :
si je remplis le bidon d'eau au départ,
je ne peux plus rien mettre dedans,
ça va déborder.
Donc en termes de gestion du temps,
il va être important
de définir ses priorités.
Pour bien définir ses priorités,
il faut distinguer les priorités
de ce qu'on appelle
le flux, l'aléa, et l'urgence.
Je vais commencer par le flux.
Le flux, c'est ce que vous faites
tous les jours, quoi qu'il arrive.
Pour vous, le flux,
c'est d'aller en cours.
Pour moi, le flux,
c'est d'animer des formations.
On passe aux aléas et aux urgences.
Je vais prendre un exemple.
Un gros client appelle votre entreprise.
Il veut que vous réalisiez quelque chose,
très rapidement.
Pour là, maintenant, tout de suite,
en général, c'est la demande.
Urgence ou aléa ?
La plupart du temps, en entreprise,
j'entends : « Urgence ».
C'est un gros client,
donc c'est une urgence.
Sur le plan sémantique,
l'urgence implique
que quelqu'un est blessé,
que quelqu'un fait un malaise,
ou qu'il y a un incendie.
La mairie d'Annecy la semaine dernière,
oui c'était une urgence.
Le gros client qui appelle et demande
de faire quelque chose très rapidement,
et que c'est important,
c'est un simple aléa en réalité.
La différence en termes de gestion
et d'organisation du temps de travail,
c'est que pour une urgence,
j'arrête tout ce que je fais
pour me mettre dessus.
Quand il y a le feu,
je ne me pose pas la question
de terminer ce que je suis
en train de faire.
Avec un aléa, je peux terminer
ce que je suis en train de faire,
aller jusqu'au bout,
et dans les deux ou trois heures
qui arrivent
donner réponse à mon client.
Alors si les priorités ne sont ni le flux,
ni l'aléa, ni encore moins l'urgence,
qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Eh bien les priorités sont
des choses importantes
qu'on ne prend pas toujours
le temps de faire,
des choses importantes
qui vont permettre de faire mieux,
de faire plus vite,
de diminuer le nombre d'aléas,
ou alors de mettre en œuvre
de nouvelles idées ou de nouveaux projets.
Ce que nous enseignent les lois du temps,
et notamment la loi de Pareto,
c'est le fameux 80/20.
C'est-à-dire que 80% de mon temps
doit être dédié à la partie bleue
pour 20% de mon temps
dédié à la partie jaune, les priorités.
20% du temps, c'est quand même important,
ça fait un peu moins de 2 heures par jour,
et ça fait une journée par semaine.
Comment placer cela
dans mon emploi du temps
si je ne les place pas dès le départ ?
Si Pierre ne les place pas dès le départ ?
S'il ne place pas son idée dès le départ,
il ne pourra pas la mettre en œuvre.
La troisième clé que je souhaite
vous délivrer,
ce sont les ennemis.
Il va falloir les combattre.
Il existe ce qu'on appelle
des « voleurs de temps »,
il y en a des internes et des externes.
Je vais commencer par les internes,
et le premier, c'est le perfectionnisme.
Peut-être vous êtes-vous dit,
pour répondre à la question
« Quels sont vos trois qualités
et vos trois défauts ?»
pour préparer vos entretiens d'embauche,
que ce serait une bonne idée de mettre
en haut de la liste de vos défauts
le perfectionnisme.
Il faut savoir que le perfectionnisme
est un gros, vilain, méchant défaut.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que quand un client, une entreprise
a un attendu qui est « là »,
quand je suis perfectionniste,
je vais avoir un attendu qui est « là ».
Et je vais gaspiller du temps
et des ressources
qui ne sont pas nécessaires.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la sur-qualité.
Pour le perfectionnisme,
faites bien, c'est déjà très bien.
Le deuxième ennemi interne,
c'est le pessimisme.
Le pessimisme est plutôt lié aux aléas.
Quand quelque chose arrive dans la journée
qui n'était pas prévu,
j'ai deux façons de le traiter.
Je peux râler,
me dire que ce n'est pas normal,
et perdre du temps,
ou alors je peux traiter cela
de manière positive,
et me dire : « Ok, ça arrive »,
c'est prévu dans mon agenda
de toute façon,
je sais rendre l'imprévisible prévisible,
et du coup, je vais le faire.
Et j'avance, et je ne perds pas de temps.
Mon troisième ennemi interne, je le nomme
la « discussion-réflexion ».
La discussion-réflexion, c'est quoi ?
C'est prendre le temps d'échanger,
discuter, de récolter de l'information,
de s'interroger sur un sujet,
et de réfléchir
avant de passer à l'action.
Alors c'est très bien,
pour la partie jaune.
Par contre, quand je suis dans le flux
ou les aléas,
il y a des méthodes, des techniques,
des procédures,
je ne me pose pas de question,
je les applique.
Et comme cela, je gagne du temps.
On passe aux ennemis externes.
Dans les ennemis externes,
celui qui arrive en numéro un,
c'est le téléphone portable.
Sachez que,
quand vous faites quelque chose,
et que vous prenez un quart de seconde
pour regarder l'heure
sur votre téléphone portable,
quand vous revenez
sur votre tâche initiale,
ce qui va se passer,
c'est qu'il y aura
un temps de concentration,
« Où en étais-je, qu'ai-je déjà fait ?
Que me reste-t-il à faire ? »
Ce temps de concentration,
il est assez important.
Si en permanence je « switche »
entre ma tâche et mon téléphone portable,
je gaspille un temps très conséquent.
Vous devez vous autoriser à travailler
en mode déconnecté,
c'est-à-dire avec le téléphone
comme aujourd'hui
en mode avion, voire éteint.
Le reste du monde continuera
à vivre sans vous.
Le deuxième fléau,
tout particulièrement en entreprise,
c'est le mail.
Il faut savoir qu'un manager de proximité
reçoit en moyenne
entre 100 et 200 mails par jour.
Cela représente 10 heures de travail
par semaine en traitement,
un jour et demi. C'est énorme.
Les conseils qui sont donnés
autour du mail,
c'est de les lire deux fois par jour,
une fois le matin, une fois l'après-midi,
ne pas les traiter au fil de l'eau,
et privilégier la voie du direct,
c'est-à-dire que ce n'est pas un média
de communication efficace,
et il vaut mieux communiquer directement
dans la vraie vie,
plutôt que par mail.
Le mail va servir à tracer l'information.
Le troisième ennemi externe,
c'est l'environnement direct.
Les amis, les collègues
qui sont à côté de nous
quand nous sommes en train de travailler.
C'est comme le téléphone,
ils nous sollicitent,
nous posent des questions,
nous racontent leur week-end
ou leurs vacances, ce genre de choses,
c'est sympa,
pour autant ça me déconcentre.
C'est très compliqué
d'appuyer sur un bouton
et d'éteindre son environnement extérieur.
Il existe des outils,
comme le casque anti-bruit.
Quand quelqu'un porte un casque,
en général, on va moins le solliciter.
Si vous pouvez travailler
dans une pièce fermée,
vous pouvez fermer la porte,
vous envoyez un signal fort.
« Je veux être tranquille ».
Certains vont jusqu'à poser un écriteau
« Séance de travail en cours.
Merci de revenir à partir de X heure. »
Ou alors le jeu de la délocalisation.
C'est en train de se développer
en entreprise, par le home office.
Home office,
ça consiste à travailler chez soi.
Les taux de productivité en home office
augmentent jusqu'à 30%,
tout simplement parce qu'on n'est pas
sollicités par l'environnement extérieur.
Voilà pour les ennemis externes.
Concrètement, si on veut aider Pierre,
comment doit-il s'y prendre ?
Tout d'abord, il va placer ses priorités
dans son agenda.
Environ 20% de son temps.
Ensuite, il va y avoir le flux.
Le flux est plus ou moins important ;
pour pouvoir le mesurer
il est conseillé de faire un budget temps.
Je commence ma journée
par ce que je n'aime pas.
Car ce que je n'aime pas,
j'ai tendance à m'en débarrasser,
à aller vite,
et la deuxième raison,
c'est que si je n'aime pas,
et que je garde pour la fin de la journée,
je risque de remettre à demain.
Et remettre à demain, on le sait tous,
c'est remettre à jamais.
Ensuite, on va traiter les mails,
deux fois par jour.
Une fois le matin, une fois l'après-midi.
Il est conseillé,
en même temps qu'on traite les mails,
d'avoir une routine.
Au-delà de boire le café et
de dire bonjour à ses collègues,
l'objectif est d'organiser
votre journée de travail -
qu'est-ce que j'ai à faire ? -
et d'organiser votre espace de travail.
Parce qu'au bout d'un certain temps,
l'efficacité décroît,
il est important de faire des pauses.
Au moins une le matin et l'après-midi,
et une vraie pause déjeuner.
Les études montrent
qu'entre 45 minutes et 1h30,
nous sommes dans notre phase optimale
de concentration.
Au-delà d'1h30, il faut faire une pause.
Ensuite arrivent les aléas.
Les aléas varient en fonction des métiers.
Certains groupes que j'ai accompagnés
avaient 30% d'aléas par jour.
Pour certaines activités,
on monte à 70% voire 80% d'aléas.
Comment rendre l'imprévisible prévisible ?
Simplement en réservant du temps
dans son emploi du temps
pour traiter les aléas.
Ce qui fait que, quand mon gros client
m'appelle pour me dire
« J'ai besoin de cela très rapidement ».
« Très bien, je le traite
aujourd'hui entre 11h et 12h.
Cela vous convient ? »
La réponse est en général Oui,
puisque la proposition
est tout à fait raisonnable.
Pour terminer, je vais finir ma journée
avec la routine du soir.
La routine du soir consiste déjà
à ranger son espace de travail
et les documents traités dans la journée,
aussi bien dans le monde réel
que dans le monde virtuel,
de manière à retrouver les choses
facilement
et ne pas perdre de temps à chercher.
Et puis terminer la journée
par ce qu'on aime.
Parce ce que ce qu'on aime,
on a tendance à y passer
un peu plus de temps.
Donc si on a envie de rentrer chez soi,
on ne va peut-être pas le faire.
Et puis surtout je vais combattre
mon perfectionnisme,
parce que je vais vouloir
rentrer chez moi.
Je vous remercie pour votre attention,
et je vous souhaite
une journée pleine d'idées.
(Applaudissements)